[موسيقى]
مساء الخير وصفه بانها ازمه دوليه او
كابوس للعالم لا مبالغه فيه والحقيقه احنا
في سوريا وقدمنا قضيتين القضيه
قضيه ادله والثاني ما يمكن ان نسميها
بقضيه شرق الفرات في شمال سوريا وال
قضيتين دول ان ننجح الاطراف المختلفه
المتصارعه في سوريا في حسم هما يمكن
لسوريا ان تبدا المفاوضات الحل السلمي
ووضعه الدستور ويعني استقرار الاوضاع هناك
وان فشلت الاطراف في حسم هاتين القضيتين
ممكن سوريا ترك على المربع رقم واحد وسوء
الاوضاع هناك هي مشكله هي مشكله شرق
الفرات
ادلب باختصار كل الناس عارفه منطقه ادلب
وما حولها انتقل يتجمع فيها عدد كبير جدا
من
المسلحين و ممن يحملون السلاح ضد نظام
بشار الاسد
ارقام حملت السلاح هناك ارقام كثيره
بيقولوا ارقام والاتراك تقول ارقام
والامريكان والنظام في النهايه احنا ودنا
عشرات الاف من حمله السلاح والاف كثيره
منهم من الاجانب الذين جاؤوا من جنسيات
مختلفه طيب بالنسبه كلها
نذكر حضراتكم انه مناطق النزاع المختلفه
اللي كانت منتشره بكامل القطر السوري
مع الضغط الروسي واه الايراني مع الجيش
السوري بدؤوا في محاصره اماكن مختلفه
لغايه ما بقت محصوره في اربعه اماكن بدايه
من مايو 2017 الى سمير باماكن خفض التصعيد
لكن اماكن الصراع الرئيسي ضد النظام هذه
الاماكن الرئيسه كانت حماه وحلب واللاذقيه
وبدا الروس في استراتيجياتها حلفائهم
الايرانيين الجيش السوري في
قدم هذه المناطق والسيطره عليها واحده بعد
اخرى وفي كل من كان يدخلها
التحالف يعني الروس والسوريين والايرانيين
كان الخيار بيعطي لمن يحمل السلاح اما بين
الموت او الخط حيا الى منطقه اخرى اختارها
بعد ان سلم سلاحه الثقيل وخرائط الالغام
الى اخره واذا هو قبل بهذه الشروط بيخرج
في حافلات بت نقله الى مكان اخر في الغالب
كان هذا المكان الاخر هي ادلى تتجمع فيه
تقريبا كل حمله السلاح والرافضين للتسويه
مع النظام في سوريا
اسباب كثيره لكن اهم من من اوائل المعاقل
اللي خرجت او صارت على نظام اللي هو نظام
بشار الاسد مع مطلع الثوره او مع مطلع
الاحداث في مارس 2011
الامر الثاني والاهم انها قريبه من الحدود
التركيه اللي هي الراعي الرئيسي
للحركات المعارضه المسلحه ضد بشار الاسد
في النهايه واحنا اصبحنا بعد تقريبا ما
انت في كل مع كل الصراع وكل بؤر النزاع في
سوريا واصبح الامر خالص
بشار الاسد احنا قدمنا احنا امام الصراع
واحده تجمع فيها كل المعارضين الحاملين
للسلاح ضد بشار الرئيسه وهي
الوقت تدور الدوائر على ادلب لانه بقاءها
اصبح بهذا الوضع امر غير ممكن غير ممكن
لانه ناخذ فكره بالنسبه للحكومه السوريه
او الرئيس بشار الاسد ولا يمكن ابدا ان
تستقبله الامور الى استعاده بقطع النظر عن
المنطقه بالغه الاهميه
خلالها يعني اه فيها معابر دوليه وفيها
طرق دوليه وانه بدونها لا يمكن تعود حركه
الاقتصاد مره اخرى بين المدن الرئيسه لكن
في النهايه بقطع النظر عن كل الاسباب دي
هو لا يمكن ان يستقر له الامور الا
باستعاده اللي ب كما استعاد كل المناطق
السابقه
بالنسبه لل روس
ادلب على هذا الوضع خطر شديد عليهم لانه
وجودهم معناه الامه بيهددوا الاستثمار هم
او مشروعهم في سوريا اللي هم استمروا فيه
بسخاء من 2015 الى الان وبالتالي لازم من
التخلص من هذه البؤره علشان تبدا عمليه
التسويه وابدا عمليه اعاده الاعمار وتستقر
المصالح الروسيه هناك
واذا هو تركهم لو يعني حتى لو هو ترك
البؤره ادلب محافظه ادلب او ما انت قد
يكون يطلقوا لانه هودا بالنسبه معدومه
رئيسه وبالتالي بداوا في استهداف ومن
منطقه في الشهور الماضيه ومهاجمه القواعد
العسكريه الروسيه اللي موجوده هناك
وبالتالي هو كمان بيستهدف على الوقت وان
هو تراكم يخربوا احياء قبل ان يطلقوا لا
في سوريا ولا في باقي مناطق العالم يستهدف
رؤوس في كل مناطق ممكن يصل وها ويصل كمان
الى
روسيا الاتحاديه نفسها يعني امنيه الروسيه
هو عدم خروج هؤلاء المسلحين احياء حفاظا
على المشروع الروسي في سوريا وعلى مصالحها
في اماكن اخرى من العالم والموقف تتفق مع
ايران الى حد كبير لان هذه الجماعات في
معظمها تعادي ايران لاسباب سياسيه واسباب
طائفي
دون الاطراف الثلاثه طيب في المقابل تركيا
بتسميه والسمات لعدم الحكومه على
لهذا بالهجوم على عده امور السبب الرئيس
اللي هي بترفع وتتكلم كل المسؤولين
الاتراك انه انا عندي في عالم عندي اكثر
من ثلاثه ونص مليون لاجئ سوري هؤلاء
يمثلون ضغطا كبيرا على الحكومه التركيه
وزاد هذا العبئ مع وجود ازمه اقتصاديه
ضربه تركيا على مدار العماله الماضيين
وبالتالي انا اسعى لاعاده هؤلاء الى سوريا
ب غير راغب في حال اندلاع عمليه عسكريه
واسعه في ادلى حوالي
ثلاثه مليون نسمه ان هؤلاء استقبل يعني
يؤدوا الى اه
مزيد من النازحين يعني استقبال تركيا
لمزيد من اللاجئين
الامر الاول الامر الثاني اللي هي ما
تقوله بصراحه انه الاتراك استثمروا في
كثير من هذه الجماعات بعضها هي مشكله
السيطره عليهم تعتبرهم جماعه ارهابيه لكن
استثمرت في جماعات اخرى
الادله فيها كثير من الجماعه اسماء كثيره
ممكن تعملوا فيها رساله ماجستير قاعده
داعش و احرار الشام
طبعا نصره بعد هيئه تحرير الشام اه وبعد
كده عندنا ما يسمى ب احرار الشام وعندنا
حره من اسماء كثيره يعني لكن كلهم في
النهايه ممكن يحسب على
الجهاديين دول الخلفيه الدينيه او
الاسلاميه تركيا استثمارات في كثير من هذه
الجماعات واستثمرت فيه الهدفين الاول
الهدف الطموح اللي بدايته ثم تخلت عنه
لانه لم تستطع تحقيقه هو اسقاط نظام بشار
الاسد تحقيقا لمشروعها اللي كانت تعتزم
قمته في سوريا ممتده خصصوا حلقه ثانيه طيب
اذا فشل هذا المشروع في حاجه لهؤلاء هذه
الجماعات لسببين اخرين زاويه الاخرين خلاف
السبب الاول ان اللي هو اسقاط بشار الاسد
اللي فشلت فيه السبب الاول ان والسبب
الثاني هو الابقاء على هذه الجماعات اوراق
ضغط في القضايا التسويه المستقبليه في
سوريا الامر الثاني انها تدخلهم للصراع
المستمر مع الكرد في شمال سوريا
وبالتالي تصفيه هذه الجماعات هي طبعا
مساله خساره كبيره لا تقبل بها تركيه او
لم تقبل بها ببساطه لكن في نفس الوقت هي
غير قادره على مقاومه الضغوط الروسيه
عليها ومعها ال الايرانيين ومعها طبعا
الحكومه السوريه طيب الحل ايه اللي بيخلي
تركيا طوال الوقت تبحث عن حلول هي قاومت
هذه الفكره على فتره طويله ولاحظنا كدا
انهم ما كانت جزء احداش تركها في اماكن
خفض التصعيد في مايو 2017 كانت الحفاظ على
هذه الجماعات ول هذه الاعتبارات ثم اتفاق
اه سوتشي في سبتمبر 2018 هي تطوع بان تكون
الضامن والمنسق لهذه الجماعات داخل ادلب
لكن هي اعترفت انها فشلت في السيطره على
الفصيل الرئيسي في هذه ال في ادلب اللي هي
نصره ولم تلتزم باتفاق وقف اطلاق النار او
خاصه التصعيد وهاجمت الجيش السوري وهاجمت
اه ادلب طبعا بين قوسين في روايه تركيه
اخرى بتقول ان نصها ب تعمل لصالح ال اه
الروس وال تعمل لصالح البشتوني بانها
المشاكل علشان تمكن الروسي لتنفيذ
مخططاتهم هي رؤيه الجانب التركي فقط في كل
الاحوال
الاطراف ازاء الضغط اسقط بينهم مش عارفين
نعمل ايه مش قادرين يقوم المساله فبدا
الروس والسوريين ومعهم حلفائهم لهم
الايرانيين يحاولون نفذه مخططهم لكن اخذين
في الاعتبار
رغبه تركيا او مخاوف تركيا من النزوح
الجماعي
وفي نفس الوقت مش بس تركيا هم اخذه في
حسبانهم مخاوف اوروبا كلها اللي بال تابع
الذي يحصل في قلب وهي تضع كل بلد ايدها
على قلبها لانه اذا حصل نزوح جماعي جماعي
مئات الالاف من
يطلعوا بس على تركيا ويعني على الحدود
تركيا من تركيا الى باقي اوروبا او من
البحر المتوسط الى باقي اوروبا تؤدي الى
مشاكل كبيره جدا
كما ادت الموقعه السابقه الاوروبي والاخطر
انه دون مش بس بعضهم لاجئين اوروبا
الكثير من هؤلاء قد يكون وجهاديين يعني
عناصر مسلحه او عناصر ارهابيه تحب الفكر
المتطرف قد تزعزع
مش عاوزه عمليه النزوح الجماعي
وفي نفس الوقت لا تستطيع ان ترفض ما
تواطات هذه الدول
مع روسيا على فكره الا يخرج هؤلاء
الجهاديين احياء من المدينه لكن في نفس
الوقت من المحافظه لكن في نفس الوقت انه
لا يكون هناك عمليه كاسحه تؤدي الى نزوح
جماعي كبير فيبدو انه الاستراتيجيه
الروسيه الان الى الاطراف يستسلموا ليها
واللي بدات من خمس يكون في جنوب ادلب
مؤخرا وعمليه بطيئه تدريجيه بدات منذ شهور
وسوف تستمر هذه العمليه تكون كما هو مخطط
تكون بطيئه تؤدي الى تنفيذ الهدف الروسي
ولا تؤدي الى موجه نزوع كما هي ضخمه في
الاطار
تركيا بتحاول تسعى
ان هي تؤسس منطقه شرق الفرات ا
علاقه منطقه شرق الفرات واللي انا بتكلم
عليه في بيصير على الخريطه اللي قدامها
هلا ان شرق الفرات اللي هو باللون الازرق
غربه يعني في الغرب من بتتكلم على الاماكن
اللي هي معظمها حضراتي في مناطق لا تمثل
خطرا على الحكومه التركيه لان هي قدره
تسيطر عليها بشكل او باخر من خلال
العمليه الدرع الفراق ومن عمليه ما زيتون
من 2016 2018
سيطرت عليها من ايه من طرد عناصرها
بتعتبرها متطرفه داعش وغيرها والاهم من
القوات الكرديه اللي هي تعتبرها جماعات
ارهابيه او بتمثل خطر عليها خصوصا جماعات
نتيجه
هذه الجماعات مازالت موجوده في شرق نهر
الفرات هل هي موجوده اللون الاصفر حتى
الحدود العراقيه هي عاوزه بتسع منذ بدء
الصراع لاقامه منطقه منها في هذه المنطقه
في المنطقه من الفراغ حتى حدود العراق لان
ال منطقه غرب نهر الفرات هي تقريبا واقع
تحت نفذها على الاقل في الوقت الحالي طيب
عشان تعمل المنطقه دي هي محل خلاف اضطرت
انه لانه انا عشان عمل المنتدى معناها انه
انا بس تهدف عنصرين العنصر الاساسي لم يعد
الموجود بشكل اساسي وهي الجماعات اللي هي
داعش وخلافه مش موجوده لان الكره تمكنوا
مع حلفائهم الامريكان وغيرهم في هذه
المنطقه طيب وبيحطوا عندهم في سجونهم
عشرات الالاف من هؤلاء الداعشيين يبقى
الهدف الاساسي هو ازاحه هذه الجماعات
الكرديه عشان تزيد هذه الجماعات الكرديه
انت كده
الامريكان لان هؤلاء لهذه الجماعات هي
الحليف الرئيسي للولايات المتحده
وكانت هيه
راس الحربه في الحرب على داعش والجماعات
الاخرى المناوئه الولايات المتحده
وبالتالي في تعارض بين الولايات المتحده
وما بين الاتراك الاتراك عن زين المنطقه
الامنيه فقط لازاحه الجماعات الكرديه
ارهابيه
اعتبرها دول العالم اخرى ارهابيا لا هما
ازاء الضغط الروسي لتصفيه الوضع في ادلب
ويامل واللي بيقول المنطقه دي كلها تحت
سيطرته من منطقه بطول حوالى 450 كيلو متر
وبعرض حوالي اثنين وثلاثه وعشرين ميلا
يعني نتكلم على حوالي ثلاثه وثلاثين كيلو
المنطقه الضخمه دي يامل من خلالها اذا هم
يتمكنوا من اقامتها ان ينجح اليها اولا
انتقل اليها عدد كبير من الجماعات اللي
هما كانت
موجوده في من اللاجئين عندها في تركيا
وتخفف الضغط عليهم الامر الثاني انه كثير
من الجماعات اللي ممكن تدخلوا من ادلب
نتيجه العمليه العسكريه ممكن يخرجوا الى
هذه المناطق ال امنها بدلا ذهابه الى
تركيا اوروبا الامر الثالث والاهم اللي
يمكن توطين فيها بشكل الامن الجماعات التي
تدين لها بالولاء الجماعات المسلحه والتي
استثمرت فيها تركيا كثيره علشان تستخدم هم
ضد النظام وقت
الكره لكن تبقى المشكله ان المنطقه الا
عمل كما يتصورها الاتراك تحقيقها على
الارض شبه مستحيل اولا لانها تصطدم بقوه
بردو يقوم مؤثره على الارض الامريكان لا
يمكن الوثوق بوعدك للاطراف خصوصا ب انهم
غير راغبين في البقاء بلدهم في شمال سوريا
الامر الثالث والمهمه ما تفتقد انه خططهم
تستقبل تفاصيل كثيره جدا منها مثلا انه كم
سنه سوف تظل هذه المنطقه العامله لفتره
مؤقته لو كانت لفتره مؤقته معناه ان
المشاكل سوف تتجدد انتهائها لو كانت بشكل
دائم هذا معنى احتلال والسوريون او
الحكومه السوريه ترفض الفكره المؤقت او
بوضعها دائما ثم هناك ايضا مشاكل اخرى
كثيره جدا تتعلق
بمفهوم المنطقه منها وتاريخ السيء في
اماكن صراع اخرى وكيف انها تؤدي الى ماسي
المواطنين الامنين او المدنيين العزل
للابرياء اللي بيجوا اليها هربا من مناطق
الصراع يجد نفسهم ايضا في جحيم من الفوضى
في هذه المناطق ما حصل في اكثر من مناطق
النزاع مختلفه مثلا زي
الصراعات فيها السابقه المختلفه في مطلع
ونظل مره اخرى انه حسب منطقه ادلب
المستعصيه على الحل وايجاد حل للمخاوف
الاكراد الاسف الاطراف في شمال سوريا هم
القضيتين الاساسيتين
ما نقدر نتكلم على امل في تسويه الصراع
السوري واذا لم يتم حل هما تعود سوريا
لقدر الله الى المربع رقم واحد اشكركم
والى اللقاء